Yeah,
inglorious bastards.
Due to my interest in water to in
general,
it's sporadic use of different
languages,
rear end damage and bolts.
Historic revisionism is my favorite
Tarantino film so far.
It was to my surprise,
therefore that film only got a 69 mets
score on MDB.
It turns out that 17 or diverting from
history angered some critics.
Jonathan Rosenbaum,
for example,
call to film deeply offensive and
morally akin to Holocaust denial to dos
critics.
The history of the Holocaust is simply
too serious for Cij revisionism,
too serious for Terantin or style or
cinematic violence,
which is violence of course,
as exciting over the top,
spectacle or even comedy.
Oh man,
a shot in the face.
Do you do that?
I didn't mean to do.
It was an accident
check.
Nutrients from now you see it argued
that with inglorious pastors,
Tarantino makes fun of his audience by
drawing a parallel between the way the
Nazis enjoyed the mindless violence and
killing innovation sprite.
As we enjoyed the final instantly tino
creates in his own film,
I was arguing for dead.
It is not quite as simple as that.
As some of the comments on now you see
it's video Poland doubts Terentino's
criticizing his audience for liking
violence would be the highest form of
hypocrisy.
Terentino's pointed out multiple times
his law for cinematic violence as fun
and entertaining spectacle I was argued
at with inglorious bastards.
Tarantino not so much criticizes his
audience for Liking Violence,
bit tune historical Lens Explorers and
reflects upon the cinematic violence and
cinema as a whole.
Many critics have pointed towards the
final scene of inglorious pastors as
Tarantino declaring the film is a
masterpiece.
My
next
yes.
If you look back in the film,
he places himself in question and more
company
when now you see it's comparison to
violence in a nation sprites to defiance
of the bastards.
He fills to see important differences in
their cinematic styles.
The Nazi film stills the nutshell or a
nation sprites,
which is featured in the climax of
inglorious bastards is a parallel to
triomphe desk villains from Leni
Riefenstahl,
who is mentioned multiple times in the
movie,
think it kind of getting you up
the
violence in the nation.
Sprite is shults into fascist the
headache.
Susan Sonntag also referring to
Riefenstahl states that the fascist
aesthetic,
our tales of longing for high places of
the men and Barf to Uber Manch while in
the area and ideal that is placed above
all else.
The boss is to the contrary,
represented multicultural collective of
the American melting pots.
They come from different places and
backgrounds and in their difference are
challenged to the area in aesthetic that
Google's promotes in a nation.
Surprise.
Now,
the opening scene often pastorates is
already a break with typical Tarantino
West cinematic violence.
Yes,
it is explosive birth.
It doesn't function so much as spectacle
or comedy as Terentino's violence
usually does.
Terentino's constructs the scene in such
a way slowly building to Hans Landa,
that explosion of violence feels quite
horrific and quite cruel.
Making this opening chapter feel more
like a scene from a holocaust film than
Terentino's normal.
Don't worry,
it's only a movie kind of violence.
Of course,
this isn't the case in the next chapter
where we meet the bastards here,
violence is both spectacle and comedy.
Although rain even directly mentioned
the link between cinema and violence as
sources of entertainment,
to hear you say that,
quite frankly,
close,
we're getting going to the movies.
These first two chapters function in two
ways.
Both teens are completely different in
their tone and fuel and violence.
She had two scenes are also very much
alike.
Both feature a commander that claims to
have come down from the mountains to
take part in the war who is in control
of the narrative and directs the scene
to watch its final conclusion.
Yet the violence in the first chapter
feels cruel and horrific while in the
second chapter at a spectacle and the
comedy,
of course,
we're in a culture we naturally and
rightfully so route for the allies and
it's not for the Nazis yet.
Tino does hint that the officer who is
beaten to death is an honorable man.
Juice.
Tarantino deffer shows that through
cinematic techniques such as the
soundtrack,
firelands can have two totally different
functions into fairly similar scene.
The second function is to make clear the
distinction between the Boston arts and
Shoshana as characters.
Although most of the bosses are Jewish,
they come from different places and
backgrounds.
They are a multicultural ragtag group
that merged into a greater American
whole with the goal to bring terror to
the Nazis were going to be doing one
thing and one thing only.
Killing Nancy's Shoshana,
however,
is defined by her identity as a Jewish
victims of the Holocaust.
For awhile she adopts the identity of a
French girl,
but she never forgets what happened to
her and her family.
Now the film builds towards a claim
where boats have Shana and the Boston
execute a revenge plots on Hitler and
Nazi Mount.
Both French plots together resulted in
what seems to be a typical Terentino's
sheen over the top violence.
Yes,
they are affect different narrative
conclusions that's compete with each
other.
The Boston burst in shoot Hitler and
goebbels to bits and then blow up the
whole theater,
including themselves.
Domain boster.
It's all the rain,
however,
survives and Indians to Boston.
It's narrative is one of the rugged
American cowboy that's rights into town,
kills the ins against impossible odds
and writes outs round recently,
scalper Herman
through this Lens.
It is indeed very arguable that
inglorious bastards to field licensed
the horror of the Holocaust and evils of
the Nazi regime against the Jewish
people.
However,
although the film ends with the Boston
Shoshana's for your French still
lingers,
which plays are darker and more
unsettling than that of the bastards
who you French for Christ or own
extinction who refer plays out from
beyond the grave,
while her image becomes embedded in
smoke,
connecting it to otherwise referenced
horrors off to concentration camps.
She rises from a moment of greatest
vulnerability as Sheila is dying to
reach an ambivalent triumph,
she has other to refer on the people who
murdered her family and countless
others,
so for people gazing at them from the
smoke and ashes of the very furnished,
constructed to destroyer s with the boss
stood staring.
Tino fulfills this revenge fantasy on
the Nazis.
True Shushana's narrative.
Yet her narrative is much more aware of
the Holocaust and Jewish suffering under
the Nazis.
The film.
This offers two distinct narratives and
the question becomes,
who has effect guilty clearer?
Who does the audience see as the main
drive for revenge?
Technically,
the pastor's son,
although gets the last word,
yet for dose watching,
it's Kenneth escaped a haunting sense
that it was someone else,
someone in the smoke that by now it's
dispersed to the winds who really killed
Hitler.
Right.
Thank you everyone for watching and
leave your thoughts below and if you
want to get access to more stuff and
help us keep making videos,
consider supporting on some patrion.
We will announce new patron rewards next
week and we asked to fill up some
awesome stuff for you guys.
Since Youtube is acting weirder and
weirder lately,
please turn on notifications for gentle
and follow us on facebook or twitter.
We will see you next week.